[Música]
es un gusto estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente en esta
edición especial analizaremos la
creciente presencia e influencia de
china en América Latina y para eso me
acompañan el estudio Alejandro Godoy
consultor geopolítico en Asia y medio
oriente Alejandro Muchas gracias por
aceptar esta invitación quiero que
empecemos contextualizando a nuestros
televidentes desde cuándo iniciaron esos
lazos entre Beijing y países de América
Latina Los lazos entre ambas regiones
son más lejanos de lo que nosotros
creemos realmente nos tenemos que
derivar al siglo 16 cuando venían aquí
grandes Navegantes como shenge y después
hacia el siglo 20 cuando llega el poder
Mao setunco después de eso cuando
el gran líder y timonel económico de
esta nación del gigante asiático
estableció una relación es muy fuertes
con América Latina
los intercambios comerciales empezaron a
subir de forma muy rápida tanto así que
para el año 1980 era de cerca de 1.300
millones de dólares y en el último año
que tenemos constancia en el 2021 cerca
de 450 mil millones de dólares es decir
un incremento supremamente grande pero
no tan beneficioso para América Latina
al día de hoy Alejandro vemos que esos
vínculos van más allá de lo comercial
incluso podemos hablar de lazos
políticos ideológicos académicos y de la
ayuda financiera que prestan bancos
chinos a varios países de América Latina
y en este punto quiero detenerme en
especial quiero que veamos el siguiente
gráfico
que lo revela el centro de pensamiento
de diálogo interamericano en el que
vemos que desde 2005 al 2018 Venezuela
fue el mayor beneficiario de estos
préstamos chinos con 62.500 millones le
sigue Brasil con 30,500 millones Ecuador
con 18.200 millones y Argentina con mil
millones de dólares estos préstamos
millonarios préstamos se siguen dando en
la actualidad o han disminuido han ido
cayendo esa parte entre el 2005 y el
2018 fue alrededor de 140 mil millones
de dólares después de eso es interesante
porque en el 2018 cayó a 7.700 millones
y del 2019 para acá realmente la
estrategia ha venido cambiando esa
estrategia hoy en día es más de la
cooperación del proyecto que llamamos
nosotros la franja y la ruta más allá de
esos préstamos sin embargo hay que
destacar aquí el rol de Venezuela porque
Venezuela porque como lo vimos en el
gráfico era el que tenía más préstamos
Pero ha cumplido en gran medida con sus
obligaciones hoy de esos 62.500 millones
de dólares solamente debe 20.000 es
decir ningún país ha caído en lo que
pensaba Estados Unidos que iba a suceder
que se llamaba la trampa del nopago
Alejandro y televidentes los invito a
que veamos el siguiente informe de
nuestro periodista Samuel Salgado en el
que hablamos de los países que
actualmente cuentan con un tlc con china
noviembre de 2016 el presidente chino
Pink recibe la orden El Sol del Perú en
el congreso peruano no importa cómo
cambia la situación internacional no
importa cómo se desarrolle china china
nunca practicará la hegemonía o la
expansión y nunca buscará círculos de
influencia
no tener un ánimo expansionista cuando
se cumplen seis años del tratado de
libre comercio entre lima y Beijing
desde que el acuerdo comercial entró en
vigor en marzo de 2010 el crecimiento
anual de los bienes peruanos exportados
a China es de 11%, mientras que los
productos chinos importados a Perú es
del 12%, según la cámara de comercio
peruano china
los productos agrícolas y pesqueros
destacan como las principales
importaciones peruanas en el mercado
chino pero también la industria y
fabricación de máquinas tratan de dejar
atrás la histórica exportación de
commodities de América Latina a las
grandes economías en la actualidad con
13 años de tlc El gigante asiático Se
ratificó como el mayor socio comercial
de Perú la estrategia peruana es
convertirse en el centro de operaciones
de Asia en América del Sur sin embargo
la inestabilidad política en el país
podría arriesgar la inversión extranjera
contrario a Costa Rica donde la
combinación de estabilidad política
contratos social y crecimiento estable
reconocida por del Banco Mundial ha
traído la inversión de la segunda mayor
Economía del mundo Costa Rica es la
mayor beneficiada de la relación con un
aumento de más del 700% en las
exportaciones a China desde que el tlc
entró en vigor en 2011 mientras que las
importaciones chinas al país
centroamericano aumentaron 129%
en Chile primer país en firmar un
tratado libre comercio con china en 2006
las exportaciones que contabilizaron más
de 97 mil millones de dólares tuvieron
como principal destino Asia en los
últimos seis años de tlc las
exportaciones chilenas a China han
aumentado 125 por ciento destacando el
litio y yodo como los principales
productos exportados
en los tres países de la región que
tienen tratados de libre comercio con
China la relación comercial ha sido
positiva un impulso para que Ecuador se
sumara en mayo de este año como el
cuarto país de la región en firmar un
tlc con China
veíamos en el informe que Ecuador es el
cuarto país de la región en firmar un
tlc con china Alejandro cuán
beneficiosos son este tipo de acuerdos y
cuáles son los riesgos para un país como
Ecuador que busca diversificar su
comercio es bastante interesante porque
ha establecido que para la próxima
década puede ganar entre 3000 y 4.000
millones de dólares adicionales en
términos no minero energéticos el punto
clave aquí que podríamos decir negativo
tiene que ver en este caso particular
con estar demasiado sesgada a una sola
economía en este caso la China y no irse
diversificando más allá control y además
los ambientalistas tienen una crítica
bastante fuerte en este tratado de libre
comercio por el tema marítimo que es uno
de los más grandes en el caso de Ecuador
ahoritica en unos hace unos momentos
sobre los socios comerciales y quiero
que veamos el siguiente mapa en el que
vemos cómo ha sido esa evolución de los
socios comerciales que ha tenido América
Latina en los últimos 12 años aquí en
este mapa podemos ver que en el año 2000
Estados Unidos era el principal Partner
o socio comercial de varios países de
América Latina y ahora vemos Que en 2022
China le cambió completamente el
panorama qué lectura podemos hacer de
esto sí uno en este tiempo Suramérica
hoy por hoy todos los países de la
nación tiene como primer socio comercial
a China frente a Estados Unidos porque
se dio Este cambio tan grande uno los
liderazgos aquí en la región se fueron
de una tendencia política que llamamos
aquí de derecha a izquierda eso también
tiene mucho que ver con la conexión Más
allá de la economía con la diplomacia y
lo que le está ofreciendo de productos
América Latina a China es también
bastante relevante esos dos factores han
hecho que se den esos cambios tan
grandes y sabemos que Estados Unidos en
esa última década abandonó realmente las
políticas económicas para acercarse a
América Latina y China y Rusia de igual
manera también colonizaron espacios
comerciales Cuáles son esos productos
que o esos intereses económicos que
tiene China en América Latina esos
productos de esta parte del mundo que
son tan apetecidos para Beijing
siguiendo lo que es el mapa vemos como
mercosur Uruguay Paraguay Brasil y
Argentina ofrecen soja Por qué soja
porque hoy por hoy en China el consumo
de carne de cerdo llega al 47% de la
población y es la alimentación de los
mismos todo el tema minero energético es
muy importante sobre todo el litio va a
ser fundamental en ese aspecto porque
estamos en una transición energética y
eso le interesa a China y aquí países
como Bolivia como Argentina y como chile
son los líderes de este aspecto y Brasil
también con el tema de los
biocombustibles la anterior y en esta el
tema de las energías alternativas como
represas en proyectos que ha hecho china
aquí en América Latina son de los más
fundamentales hoy por hoy Bueno ahora
quiero que hablemos de esa famosa
llamada ruta y franja de la seda Qué es
y Cuál es la importancia Bueno lo
primero lleva una década en su
Constitución empezó en el año 2013
cuando el líder
estableció en la universidad de nazar
bayev en kazajistán la necesidad de
volver a retomar un proyecto tan
relevante que duró 15 siglos lo llamamos
la franja y la ruta porque es la franja
marítima y la ruta terrestre que hoy por
hoy tiene cerca de 90 países que la
constituyen y donde América Latina
también empieza a tener un rol
trascendental porque que ha dicho
somos naciones del sur y necesitamos en
ese aspecto mejorar todo lo que es
nuestro comercio pero más allá del
comercio tecnología política sociedad y
digitalización que también es muy
importante en esta en este proyecto esos
países que estamos viendo que no hacen
parte
aún de la seda podrían en algún momento
en algún escenario hacer parte por
supuesto Qué se debe hacer en el proceso
un memorando de entendimiento entre los
gobiernos de igual manera países que no
pertenecen hoy por hoy al mismo pero que
tienen intereses porque la tecnología es
muy importante y el tema de proyectos de
infraestructura como lo vemos en países
como Colombia con la construcción de la
primera línea del metro el regiotran de
tren de cercanías eso ya conlleva que
más temprano que tarde realmente Las
Naciones latinoamericanas que no están
presentes en el proyecto empiecen a
acercarse digamos que como máximo en los
próximos tres años quiero que andemos un
poco más en esos productos que nosotros
le exportamos a China Cuáles son esos de
Gran importancia y que china dice Bueno
América Latina es clave en la cuna de
productos como llamamos cemento el
cemento es fundamental porque hoy por
hoy cerca del 60% del cemento que se
consume en el mundo va a China el tema
obviamente petróleo sigue siendo
bastante relevante como lo mencionábamos
anteriormente una forma en que Venezuela
ha pagado parte de los préstamos litio
en este caso particular el oro del siglo
XXI el oro del Siglo 21 Así es Y con el
tema de los granos también ha tenido una
interesante propuesta a los países de
mercosur cobre de igual manera es muy
relevante y productos marítimos también
de El caso concreto de Ecuador
Alejandro Cómo van las cosas y con este
análisis que hemos hecho a lo largo de
este programa Hasta qué punto seguirían
las inversiones de china en América
Latina yo consideraría que en el próximo
lustro en los próximos cinco años va a
seguir la firma de tratados de libre
comercio hay algunos mercados
importantes como Brasil con el cual aún
no tiene este tipo de de acuerdo
comercial y de otro lado también
mientras haya reservas minero
energéticas aquí en América Latina la
presencia de China va a seguir siendo
constante Alejandro Muchas gracias por
haber aceptado esta invitación
y a ustedes televidentes Les agradecemos
su sintonía en este en esta edición
especial de acidez a Hacienda que
analizamos la creciente presencia y
influencia de América Latina en nuestra
región Los invito a que manden sus
comentarios a la cuenta de Twitter que
aparece en sus pantallas y a visitar
nuestra página web France 24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]